have a challenging childhood with
unreliable reckless or scary parents
then try never to think about understand
or digest what you've been through grow
up into an extremely romantic person
with a firm conviction that there is
someone out there who will entirely
understand and heal the broken parts of
you foster a faith in the one an angel
in human form dismiss a lot of
candidates with healthy emotional
backgrounds by saying that they are
boring head for someone with similarly
grave psychological wounds but far more
importantly with an equal commitment to
not understanding themselves spend a lot
of money on a huge wedding think at
length about seating plans and flowers
don't go anywhere near a marriage
therapist acquire some distinctive
communication skills where when you are
annoyed you don't really let on maybe
drink or chop wood instead ask yourself
if it's normal to be a bit unhappy with
someone sometimes and answer with a firm
no trust that life for others is a bed
of roses feel very justified in your own
positions nurture self-righteousness
stick to your guns be very insistent and
keen on identifying your partner's
wrongdoings become a forensic expert in
their floors adopt a general line that
it's always the other person's fault be
very good at explaining why criticism of
you is misguided and cruel always
believe that any feedback about you is
malevolent insist that love is about
accepting the whole of you every single
bit always measure your current
sentiment against the happiest day of
your honeymoon and be very good at
noting how far it's fallen
carefully compare your daily experience
with the media representations of newly
engaged celebrities draw frequent
attention to the aging process as it
affects your partner blame them for not
taking care of themselves enough
frequently identify people in the street
with whom you might be much happier
point them out to your partner watch a
lot of porn and judge your own sexual
life by comparison notice how many
disappointing characteristics and your
own children are the fault of your
partner and your partner's family draw
enormous inferences from your partner's
irritating quirks of behavior around the
kitchen and bathroom often ruminate on
what potential damage your partner could
have done to your career take your anger
and disappointment with your partner and
directed towards having an affair argue
that divorce is just an accident means
nothing and that children won't mind get
a divorce remarry add tears start again
you